for your houston astros getting loose to
start game two of this double-header
it will be his seventh start of the
season great numbers across that bottom
line that lead up to that 2.29 era
leading the way for the houston astros
rotation with justin berlander on the il
well this is interesting apparently it's
ramon lariano leading on and it's the
first time in a long time someone other
than simeon has let off the ball game
and the 1-1 pitch to ramone and that
swung on lifted and hit well right
center phil reddick going deep in the
alley he'll turn and watch it fly and
loriana with a lead-off home run and
that quickly it's one nothing in favor
of the a's
that's the way baseball goes certainly
ramon didn't forget what it was all
about get your team on the board as
quickly as possible he used to hit very
well here at minutemaid park in his
career as good as he was against the
astros previously he has not been that
good in his last two starts
his last two starts and six in the third
innings pitch he's given giving up 13
earned runs a lot of pitches from zach
grenky in the first inning and the
astros are trying to return the favor
here to frankie montas
ball four bases will be loaded oh yuli
got down on the count 0-1 and then
montas missed with the next four pitches
now the astros have the bases loaded and
their hottest hitter kyle tucker is
coming up
tucker sends one into right center field
well hit biscotti on the move he won't
get there splits the outfielders
springer's in bradley's in julie's being
waved around he's in three rbi triple
for the triples leader in the major
leagues kyle tucker and it's three
nothing three to one astro
pretty impressive swings we've seen from
kyle tucker here in recent weeks i am
not sure why they continue to throw him
off speed so that's what i like about
kyle tucker is he's ready to hit but
when he gets the mistakes he's not
missing him
six triples on the year no other major
leaguer started the day with more than
three so the astros get the lead off
walk and the lineup turns over to
springer just about decision time for
bob melvin on what he wants to do with
his starting pitcher george sends one
way out of here
springer
way up on the train tracks the four
train has just left union station with a
two-run home run and it's now a five to
one game
i'm not sure that's gonna register on
stack ass that ball was absolutely
obliterated
oh my goodness
that is full extension
jonah high and rookie catcher has a
front row view of what absolute towering
missile looks like coming off the bat of
george
wow
astros lead 5-1 matt chapman frankie's
retired eight in a row the last man to
reach was chapman
chapman a shot toward the corner and
that baby is gone so chapman with his
tenth home run of the year it's five to
two he's batting a thousand as a
shortstop
he's been miscast his entire career
115.9 miles an hour on the exit velocity
yeah that ball got out of here in a
hurry
chapman so strong zach reinke 77 pitches
getting ready to start work here in the
fifth he's allowed total solo home runs
to ramon lariano leading off the game
paul's hit hard be mile machine has
himself a base hit
on a 2-1 pitch
he's a one out base runner here for the
a's in the fifth inning machine takes
his lead here's the 1-1 pitch and ramon
rips it down the left field line hooking
in the corner of faribault rattling
around in there it's in play machine is
around second going to third and
laureato will go to second with a double
and he is making some noise in the fifth
inning as they have runners at second
and third mariano has been right on some
of those
fastballs
a heck of a job by carlos correa knowing
minutemaid park as well as he does that
ball getting away from tucker as it hit
hard off the manual scoreboard chapman
now five for 13 in his career against
cranky with double in a home run
popped up
on the infield oled miss diaz stumbling
around but he puts it away for the final
out of the fifth inning oled miss makes
the play and zach has gone through five
here it's 5-3 houston and mcfarland
trying to
work his way out of a jam they lead from
first and second and the one-two pitch
to diaz is a ground ball and smothered
at third machine diving gets a froze to
first in time for the wood a great play
in saving a run by v mile machine diving
to his left into the hole scrambled to
his feet and fired across the diamond
and they take care of diaz and they keep
the astros off the board so now the
bases will be loaded for uli guriel
brantley now six for 13 against sorry in
his career
now falling to left field moving over
grossman he'll make the play tagging up
at third base as maldonado the throw
goes to third sac fly by eule it's now a
six to three game julie guriel drives it
a run back to back k's for pressly with
a three-run lead and now machine is next
swinging and a miss pressly strikes out
the side punches the glove and the
astros have a double-header sweep